THAT TONIGHT.
WHAT WE STILL DON’T KNOW, THAT’S
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
BEYOND THE MASSIVE HEALTH
IMPLICATIONS, THE WUHAN PANDEMIC
HAS UPENDED OUR LIVES AND THROWN
OUR ECONOMY INTO A COMPLETE
TAILSPIN.
LET’S REVIEW WHAT WE KNOW AND
WHAT WE STILL DON’T KNOW ABOUT
THE CURRENT OUTBREAK.
FOR STARTERS, WE KNOW THAT
COVID-19 IS THE LATEST
CORONAVIRUS TO AFFECT AND KILL
PEOPLE ACROSS THE GLOBE.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED WITH OTHER
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAKS.
IN NOVEMBER 2002, SARS -- OR
SEVERE ACUTE RESPIRATORY
SYNDROME -- WAS DISCOVERED IN
SOUTHERN CHINA.
IT AFFECTED MORE THAN 8,000
PEOPLE WORLDWIDE AND HAD A DEATH
RATE OF 10%.
NO ONE DIED IN THE U.S. AND IT
WAS LARGELY OVER BY JULY OF
2003.
THE FIRST CASE OF AND ERS -- IT
SPREAD THROUGH CONTACT WITH
CAMELS AND CLOSE
PERSON-TO-PERSON INTERACTION
SUCH AS CARING FOR AN INFECTED
PERSON.
MORE THAN 2400 WERE AFFECTED
GLOBALLY WITH MORE THAN 850
DEATHS, ONLY TWO CASES WERE EVER
FOUND HERE.
BOTH IN HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
WHO HAD TRAVELED TO
SAUDI ARABIA.
THE CASE FATALITY RATE WAS
APPROXIMATELY 35%.
THEN THERE IS THE NEWEST VIRAL
BEAST COVID-19.
SO FAR, THESE ARE THE STATS --
THE VIRUS IS AN ALMOST 150
COUNTRIES AND TERRITORIES WITH
NEARLY 200,000 AFFECTED, NEARLY
A THOUSAND DEATHS.
IN THE U.S., WE ARE JUST RAMPING
UP TESTING THANK GOODNESS AND SO
FAR WE HAVE NEARLY 6300
INFECTIONS AND 105 DEATHS.
WE KNOW MOST OF THE VICTIMS ARE
ELDERLY OR OTHERWISE INFIRM
INDIVIDUALS.
BUT THERE ARE MANY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS VIRUS THAT
REMAIN AND THE ANSWERS ARE GOING
TO TELL US WHETHER THE MEDIATION
ACTIONS WE HAVE TAKEN --
SHELTERING IN PLACE, WHAT WE’RE
DOING NOW -- WERE RIGHT OR
WRONG.
TOO MUCH OR TOO LITTLE.
NUMBER ONE, THE TRUE MORTALITY
RATE -- AS THE GUARDIAN REPORTED
A DAY WE DON’T YET KNOW HOW
DANGEROUS THE CORONAVIRUS IS AND
WE WON’T KNOW UNTIL MORE DATA
COMES IN.
ESTIMATES RANGE FROM BELOW 1% TO
OVER 14% AMONG SENIORS OR THE
MEDICALLY COMPROMISED.
HERE IN THE U.S. IT SEEMS THE
MORE WE TEST, THE LOWER THE
MORTALITY RATE, THAT MAKES
EVERYONE FEEL A LITTLE BETTER --
THAT GRAPH TELLS THE STORY.
NUMBER TWO, CONTAGIOUSNESS.
PEOPLE ARE TERRIFIED THEY’RE
GOING TO GET THE DISEASE BY JUST
WALKING BY SOMEONE ON THE STREET
OR IN THE GROCERY STORE, GOING
OUT TO GET MILK AND SITTING NEXT
TO SOMEONE IN THE DOCTOR’S
OFFICE FOR JUST 5 MINUTES.
DR. RICHARD MARTIN MELO AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASE SPECIALIST AT
YALE SAID THERE’S STILL SO MUCH
TO LEARN ABOUT HOW THIS PATHOGEN
IS TRANSMITTED BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS.
DATA IS NEEDED NOT ONLY TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHEN THOSE
BECOME ILL SHED THE VIRUS BUT
ALSO WHICH BODY FLUIDS CONTAIN
THE VIRUS AND HOW THOSE MAY
CONTAMINATE SURFACES AND EVEN
THE AIR SURROUNDING THEM.
THERE WAS ALSO AN IMPORTANT
STUDY CONDUCTED BY STANFORD
RESEARCHER ON THE CONFIRMED
INSTANCE OF THE VIRUS SPREADING
PERSON-TO-PERSON IN THE U.S.
IT WAS A WOMAN IN HER 60s WHO
RETURNED TO THE U.S. FROM CHINA
IN MID-JANUARY.
OF HER 372 TRACE CONTACTS, A
STUDY PUBLISHED IN THE LANCET
FOUND THAT THEY HAVE ONLY
DETECTED TRANSMISSION OF THE
SPECIFIC NAME OF THE DISEASE,
NOT THE CORONAVIRUS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT -- IN A SINGLE
HOUSEHOLD CONTACT WITH FREQUENT
PROLONGED INTERACTIONS WITH THE
PATIENTS.
IF OUT OF THREE HUNTED SEVEN TO
CONTACTS, ONLY ONE PERSON WHO
LIVED WITH HER, HER HUSBAND GOT
IT.
WHY SOME PEOPLE GET SICK AND
SOME DON’T.
WE DON’T KNOW WHY SOME OF THOSE
HAVE ONLY MILD COLD LIKE
SYMPTOMS WHY A SIGNIFICANT
MINORITY OF THOSE AFFECTED MAY
HAVE SERIOUS SYMPTOMS AT LEAST
IN PNEUMONIA AND DEPTH.
ONE THEORY IS THAT THE SEVERITY
OF SYMPTOMS IS LINKED TO THE
STRENGTH OF A PERSON’S GENERAL
IMMUNE SYSTEM.
THAT’S JUST ONE POSSIBLE
EXPLANATION.
NUMBER FOUR.
PATIENT IS ZERO?
WE STILL DON’T KNOW WHO THE
FIRST PATIENT WAS WHO CONTRACTED
THE VIRUS IN CHINA.
THAT’S A KEY FACT THAT A LOT OF
RESEARCHERS SAY IS ESSENTIAL TO
THE ANALYSIS OF THIS DISEASE.
WE FIRST HEARD LATE DECEMBER,
THEN IT WAS DECEMBER 1ST COME ON
NOW REPORTS TO GET ALL THE WAY
BACK TO NOVEMBER 17TH.
THIS MEANS THAT THE CORONAVIRUS
STARTED SPREADING FOR WEEKS
BEFORE THE FIRST CASES WERE
OFFICIALLY REPORTED BY CHINA.
THAT BRINGS ME TO THE QUESTION
NUMBER FIVE, TRUSTING THE
CHINESE.
AS SOON AS WORD GOT OUT ABOUT
THIS NEW POTENTIALLY DEADLY
VIRUS, THE CCP BEGAN TO CRACK
DOWN ON JOURNALISTS FOR DOING
THEIR JOB.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED IN
JANUARY WHEN A GROUP OF
HONG KONG JOURNALISTS WENT TO
THE WUHAN HOSPITAL THAT TOOK IN
MOST CORONAVIRUS PATIENTS, THE
POLICE DETAINED THEM FOR A FEW
HOURS.
THEY WERE ASKED TO DELETE THEIR
TV FOOTAGE AND HAND IN THEIR
PHONES AND CAMERAS FOR
INSPECTION.
TODAY, CHINA ANNOUNCED IT WAS
EXPELLING AMERICAN JOURNALISTS
FROM "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
"THE WASHINGTON POST," AND
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"."
THEY CITED IDEOLOGICAL BIAS
AGAINST CHINA, FAKE NEWS MADE IN
THE NAME OF PRESS FREEDOM AND
BREACHES OF ETHICS IN JOURNALISM
JOURNALISM.
CHINA’S MOTIVATION IS OBVIOUS,
IT FURTHER ALLOWS THEM TO
DEPRIVE US AND OF THEIR OWN
PEOPLE OF REAL INFORMATION,
ACCURATE INFORMATION ON WHAT THE
HECK IS GOING ON AND WHAT
HAPPENED ORIGINALLY WITH ITS
CORONAVIRUS.
>> I REGRET CHINA’S DECISION TO
FURTHER CLOSE THE WORLD’S
ABILITY TO CONDUCT PREPRESS
OPERATIONS WHICH WOULD BE REALLY
GOOD FOR THE CHINESE PEOPLE.
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING GLOBAL
TIMES, MORE INFORMATION, MORE
TRANSPARENCY ARE WHAT WILL SAVE
LIVES.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF SAVING
LIVES, WE DON’T KNOW WHAT THE
FATE IS OF THE TWO CITIZEN
JOURNALISTS WHO DISAPPEARED LAST
MONTH AFTER QUESTIONING THE
GOVERNMENT’S RESPONSE TO THE
VIRUS, THEY ARE JUST GONE.
QUESTION NUMBER SIX, CHINA’S
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE W.H.O.
REMEMBER CHINA IS COFOUNDER OF
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
AND IT PROVIDES AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF FUNDING TO IT, THEY
ARE NOW THE SECOND LARGEST DONOR
AFTER UNITED STATES.
SOMEHOW THEY SEEM TO BE PULLING
ALL THE STRINGS.
CNN IS REPORTING THE W.H.O.’S
CRAZE OF CHINA’S RESPONSE HAS
LED CRITICS TO QUESTION A
RELATIONSHIP.
PERHAPS ONE OF THE MOST OVERT
EXAMPLES OF THEIR SWAY OVER THE
W.H.O. IS SUCCESS IN BLOCKING
TAIWAN’S ACCESS TO THAT BODY, A
POSITION THAT COULD HAVE VERY
REAL CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
TAIWANESE PEOPLE IF THE VIRUS
TAKES HOLD THERE.
WHEN YOU HEAR OF OFFICIALS HERE
OR JOURNALISTS, COMMENTATORS
LAUDING THE CHINESE CONTAINMENT
OF THE VIRUS, TAKE THAT ALL WITH
A VERY LARGE GRAIN OF SALT.
REMEMBER, WE ARE WISE TO HEED
EXPERT ADVICE FROM TRUSTED U.S.
SOURCES BUT WE SHOULD ALSO
REMEMBER THAT THERE IS A LOT WE
DO NOT KNOW AND A LOT OF
INFORMATION COMING FROM CHINA